in 1962 after seeing the success of the
thing from the Fantastic Four and the
fan bases love for less than perfect
characters and Marvel Comics Stanley
Jack Kirby and Paul Rodman introduced a
character who is conceived after
borrowing elements from dr. Jekyll and
mr. Hyde The Hunchback of Notre Dame and
Frankenstein while his initial
popularity fizzled this character began
to find success and tales to astonish
and being featured alongside other major
comic-book superheroes and groups
including spider-man The Avengers and
the Fantastic Four this rise in
popularity ultimately led this character
to become a household name and to this
day remains one of the mainstays in
Marvel Comics what's going on guys this
is Rob and today we're going to be
talking about the Incredible Hulk
so one of the things that a lot of
people don't know and this is really
kind of funny is that the Incredible
Hulk never really had his own standalone
series he did to a degree but not in the
sense that it was a standalone series
from its inception up until now the
Incredible Hulk initially had a six-run
series it was just called The Incredible
Hulk and they ran from May 1962 to March
of 1963 but again his popularity fizzled
he really wasn't that big of a deal and
I speculate that the reason why this is
was because the Fantastic Four already
had the thing one of the things that
we've discussed is that when there is an
incarnation of a character or a team and
then another team very similar to them
or another character very similar to
them as introduced the secondary version
is really kind of discarded for example
with the x-men in our expert video we
talked about how the Fantastic Four was
the first superhero team to exist in
Marvel it was Marvel's counter to the
Justice League of America and then the
x-men popped up and the x-men really
weren't that popular because at the time
the Fantastic Four were already
established well much like with the
Incredible Hulk the thing was already an
established character and he had already
proven himself to be extremely popular
among comic book fans and so when the
Incredible Hulk was introduced a lot of
people looked at the Hulk and they
simply said this is just a human-looking
version of the thing and I imagine a lot
of people kind of discarded the
Incredible Hulk and just continued
reading about the thing now the Hulk
eventually kind of became one of the
mainstays and a series called hills to
astonish which ran from 1964 to 1968 up
until that point tales to astonish had
been a kind of sci-fi series were
various artists who were kind of
up-and-coming in Marvel Comics weren't
really able to write on major or weren't
really able to have anything to do with
major characters the x-men Fantastic
Four things like that but they could
write in tales to astonish and they
could demonstrate their ability to
create artistic renderings or they could
demonstrate their ability to tell a
story and this is really kind of where
the Incredible Hulk gained his
popularity this is really where he kind
of began to solidify himself as a
mainstay in Marvel Comics he appeared in
an issue of spider-man he appeared and I
think for issues of the Fantastic Four
although I might have muddled eb-3 and
he improved himself to be a popular
guest star and
Marvel kind of builds on this popularity
and in 1968 I think was April of 1968
they basically switched hills to
astonish to an Incredible Hulk series
and they called it the Incredible Hulk
and it started with 192 and ran to 474
now eventually this really kind of
stopped in March of 1999 and The
Incredible Hulk got his own series back
again it was just the Incredible Hulk
instead of the Incredible Hulk being
involved in a mishmash of stories or
instead of him being involved in a comic
book that also had other stories
involving other characters like ant-man
or Namor the Submariner instead it was
just the Incredible Hulk
now during tales to astonish we got a
lot of backstory about the Incredible
Hulk we learned a lot of different
things about and we learned that his
alter ego of course is actually a guy
named Bruce Banner we learned about
Bruce Banner being super smart we
learned about the powers of the
Incredible Hulk different things like
that but it wasn't until the Incredible
Hulk got his own title that a lot of
people began to take him a lot more
seriously than they did before and so
you can imagine it as a chart of sorts
of course you have this baseline zero or
one where the Incredible Hulk has issues
number one through six from May of 1962
to March of 1963 and then you kind of
see this little bit of peaking going on
between October 1964 and March of 1968
during tales to astonish and then this
peak really kind of jumps up and in the
Incredible Hulk number 102 to number 474
between April 1968 and March of 1999 and
then it really just kind of BAM explodes
and that's why you saw things like The
Incredible Hulk film we actually saw two
versions of that one with Eric Bana and
of course one with Edward Norton one of
the reasons why the Incredible Hulk was
someone who was pushed so strongly to
become a member of the Avengers in the
Avengers film he really is kind of a
mainstay here but to me one of the more
intriguing elements about the Incredible
Hulk is the same kind of comparison that
you see with dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde in
the book dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde mr.
Hyde was of course the violent alter ego
of dr. Jekyll and often times dr. Jekyll
was afraid of mr. Hyde not necessarily
of the of his existence but because of
what he would do when he came out mr.
Hyde was a very violent individual he
was a very violent character and he
would kill for the sheer pleasure of it
he would rob for the sheer pleasure of
it
he was really kind of a physical
manifestation in the book of the darker
side of not only dark dr. Jekyll but the
darker side of humanity and with the
Incredible Hulk I really feel like it's
that way
you know eventually we see Betty Ross
killed off and that was Marvel's excuse
to bring back the savage Hulk and this
really I think kind of represented the
savage side of humanity in terms of
Marvel Comics now that doesn't mean that
the Incredible Hulk is non-thinking and
unable to rationalize the Incredible
Hulk is able to think on a base level
and his intelligence is really kind of
increased over the years but it's not on
the same level as Bruce Banner Bruce
Banner has a genius-level intellect and
you won't really see the Incredible Hulk
sitting in a lab mixing chemicals and
looking to see what happens but the
Incredible Hulk is I think for all
intents and purposes a perception a
viewpoint of the savage side of humanity
you know when you look at humanity
overall when you look at our history
we've done some pretty heinous things
we've obliterated entire cultures off
the face of the map we've pushed entire
cultures to the brink of extinction all
in the name of things such as manifest
destiny or the need to expand you know I
think that when you look at the
Incredible Hulk he is kind of the
reflection of the darker side of us of
the savage side of us the
no-holds-barred unrelenting force and I
think that one of the cool things here
is that much like The Incredible Hulk
and his limitless strength the
propensity for Humanity to be savage
really has no limit there's no end it's
just how terrible we can be I mean
despite you know I guess when you look
at the fact that we've we've wiped out
entire cultures when you look at at
places like Arlington Cemetery a massive
cemetery dedicated to the countless
bodies of soldiers American soldiers who
have died in conflict it really kind of
gives you this perception that humanity
is always going to have a darker side is
always going to have a negative side and
that's one of the reasons why I think
it's interesting that the Incredible
Hulk never went away there was no cure
there was no way for Bruce Banner to get
rid of the Incredible Hulk because there
really isn't a way for Humanity to get
rid of our darker side and for us to get
rid of that aspect of us that would do
harm to not only those around us but to
the world as a whole now with regards to
the incredible hoax involvement and you
know with a lot of other characters
um the incredible Hawks really really
fascinating too he's really interesting
in terms of just his physical strength
I mean imagine a being with virtually no
limit to how strong they can get now
with the Incredible Hulk
there's there's some misperception here
in terms of how his physical strength
work a lot of people believe that the
angrier the whole can get the stronger
that he gets but that's not really how
it works this is really kind of the
angrier he stays the longer he stays
angry the stronger he gets so there
really is like a finite point at which
he can stop being angry where he's just
as angry as he's going to be but his
power continues progressing he keeps
getting stronger and stronger the longer
that he stays angry there was actually a
point in the comics called the Secret
Wars and this was an instance where a
character called the Beyonder who was
the entire sentience of a different
universe from another dimension crossed
over in ours and he created kind of this
battle planet and he took some of the
best some of the biggest superheroes
most powerful superheroes and most
popular superheroes and pitted them
against some of the most popular and
powerful villains of the time and he had
analyzed the Incredible Hulk and found
what I think he referred to as no
infinite point with end or no finite
point within meaning that there was no
point at which the Incredible Hulk would
stop being strong he would just simply
go you just stay strong forever just
keep getting stronger and stronger and
stronger The Incredible Hulk has also
had some really interesting storylines
to is really fantastic storylines Planet
Hulk World War Hulk different things
like that now the Planet Hulk storyline
was a point where the Illuminati I think
it was which was a kind of a group of
some of the top minds and top I guess
some of those most prominent leaders in
Marvel Comics Doctor Strange Ironman
Professor Xavier where they had realized
that due to the fact that the Incredible
Hulk
once enraged to a point where he was no
longer thinking he was just a fighting
and destroying being once he reached
that point he would become a danger to
the world itself and so they kicked him
out of the planet they sent him away and
he ended up on this place called battle
world her battle planet or something
like that I came over exactly what it
was called but eventually he found his
way back to earth and he really just
kind of unleashed hell on everyone
and that was the World War Hulk
storyline it's also said that the
Incredible Hulk is stronger than all
mortals and some immortals meaning that
in terms of his physical strength he's
really on a god-like kind of level there
are very few people and the Marvel
Comics who can challenge the Incredible
Hulk on a physical level the most
notable example I can probably think of
would be the juggernaut and the only
instance where you saw the Incredible
Hulk overpower the juggernaut was during
the Age of Apocalypse storyline and that
was with with the Incredible Hulk being
imbued with additional powers or having
his powers enhanced by apocalypse when
he was the horseman war I think it was
but aside from that there really isn't
anyone who can physically challenged him
The Incredible Hulk really kind of finds
his weaknesses based on who he's
fighting but more often than not it's
someone who possesses an extreme variant
of a non-physical power or someone who
is a telepath for example the century
the century was a being who could admit
these kind of not really not like a
radiation of kinds but kind of like
maybe these pheromones that could calm
the hope down the century was also able
to fight the Hulk and a fully enraged
state meaning he could go toe-to-toe but
he couldn't physically defeat him Jean
Grey for example was able to separate
the conscious mind of Bruce Banner from
the Incredible Hulk
during the onslaught storyline and The
Incredible Hulk was very able to
physically tear a hole and an onslaught
armor The Incredible Hulk is a very
powerful character in Marvel Comics he
is raw physical strength personified
that's really the best way to describe
him he is the epitome of a physically
strong character but aside from that
there really isn't a whole lot to him
so with that being said I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace